comment vous allez euh j'espère que ça
va j'espère que vous allez bien
d'ailleurs dites-le-moi dans les
commentaires alors je vous l'annonce
direct Franck billet hein regardez j'ai
pris plein de notes pour venir vous
parler des futurs smartphone de Samsung
et smartphone les plus haut de gamme la
gamme S alors je sais qu'il existe une
autre gamme qui est très haut de gamme
c'est la gamme Z on se parle des pliable
mais là on se parle de la gamme S la
gamme S elle est accès performance photo
et alors on regarde ce qui va se passer
en 2023 parce que les rumeurs sont là il
y a des choses qu'on sait il y a des
choses qu'on commence à avoir à dessiner
a priori c'est smartphone pourraient
être annoncé très bientôt d'ici un mois
alors au moment où je fais cette vidéo
vous voyez on est fin décembre début
janvier ça se passe pas là à peu près
quelque chose comme ça donc aujourd'hui
on va regarder deux choses 1 ce qu'on
sait déjà sur les futurs Samsung Galaxy
S23 qui vont arriver très bientôt et
puis ensuite les différentes rumeurs on
va regarder on a plein d'images du
smartphone plein de fuite plein de
rumeurs vous allez voir ça va être super
intéressant alors vous êtes prêts on y
va
on a commencé par le commencement le
commencement c'est quoi c'est ce qu'on
sait on sait deux choses la première on
sait que cette année ça c'est vraiment
exceptionnel et c'est génial on ne
retrouvera pas les processeurs exinos de
Samsung à l'intérieur des Samsung Galaxy
S23 on retrouvera le processeur le plus
haut de gamme de quoi le com à savoir le
stade dragon 8 Jane II je vous ai
présenté je suis allé voir indirectement
à why donc je vous ai fait une vidéo
aller jeter un œil comme ça vous saurez
tout sur ce processeur il est super
intéressant il y a plein de
fonctionnalités beaucoup de choses axées
sur l'intelligence artificielle donc
j'imagine que Samsung va faire à peu
près la même chose va travailler ses
smartphones autour de l'intelligence
artificielle c'est le premier point
c'est vraiment super intéressant et puis
le deuxième point qu'on sait bien
évidemment c'est que ces smartphones
seront sur Android 13 basés sur One uye
5.1 a priori donc ça également on en
reparlera très bientôt donc ça c'est
vraiment super cool et c'est ce qui va
arriver l'année prochaine heure
maintenant il y a plein de rumeurs c'est
à dire qu'il y a des images que j'étais
chercher pour vous sur le web on
commence à avoir des choses à commencer
par ça alors regardez-moi ce truc ça
c'est l'intérieur du smartphone ça
pourrait être à l'intérieur on porte
toujours des pincettes quand on parle de
rumeurs de fuite parce que ça permet
d'avoir une tendance à mettre sentir un
peu ce qui va arriver pour autant tout
n'est pas avéré ça ça pourrait
ressembler à ça ça serait le S23
ultra alors on regarderait les mêmes
références cette année à savoir S23 S23
plus S23 ultra 3 smartphone tout en
sachant que le S23 et S23 + serait très
similaire une différence au niveau de la
taille au niveau de la batterie mais si
on serait sensiblement la même chose
tandis que le S23 ultra lui c'est tout
autre chose un format qui est un peu
plus grand différent avec un S Pen qui
vient remplacer feu les galaxies notre
monde des images d'un côté de l'autre ça
serait sur la tranche gauche il y aurait
pas grand chose un écran on voit qu'on a
des bords qui serait assez carré ça
serait assez assez intéressant par
rapport au S23 et 23 plus que je vais
vous montrer dans quelques instants
pourquoi est-ce que j'ai pas là le
logement pour le spawn qu'on voit pas
toujours les choses avec des avec des
pincettes et voyez ça sera un format un
peu plus long alors ce qui est
intéressant est-ce que je vois au
travers de toutes ces images c'est que
on aurait surtout ces smartphones
effectivement un bouton qu'on retrouve
ici pour venir je pense l'allumer
l'éteindre peut-être pour appeler Bixby
allez savoir le bouton de volume et ici
un énorme capteur d'empreinte digitale
pourquoi c'est pour le point
d'interrogation que aujourd'hui pourquoi
est-ce que ça me saoule nous mettrait
pas un bouton pour venir l'allumer
l'éteindre avec un capteur d'empreinte
digitale donc là vous voyez ce truc un
peu zarbi mais qu'on retrouve sur les
photos des s23-23 plus 163 ultra vous
allez voir on va continuer comme ça et
là ça serait sur le haut ok voilà ce
qu'il y a pour l'instant sur ce
smartphone on va continuer avancer vous
allez voir que c'est vachement cool on
continue si ça serait sur le S23 ultra
alors toujours des images de S23 ultra
alors on va qu'on regarde à peu près la
même forme qu'on avait l'année dernière
à savoir des blocs photos qui se
détachent il y aurait pas de de partir
là qui viendrait l'intégrer comme on
avait sur les 22 ultra ni plus ni moins
donc on reste vraiment dans cette
continuité pour autant et c'est vrai que
c'est super intéressant parce que si
vous regardez les images qui sortent des
S23 plus S23 ultra et bien honoré cette
même philosophie au niveau du design ce
même truc ça c'est cool parce que ça
tranche rien un peu par rapport au S22
plus qu'on avait l'année dernière ça
apporterait autre chose il faut croire
que ce design du S22 ultra avait
beaucoup plus et qu'on viendrait
retrouver ici donc moi j'aime bien cette
idée je trouve sympa parce que alors il
y a des gens qui diront j'aime pas ça
fait un peu plaque de cuisson bon on
avait déjà ces trucs là sur les iPhone
il y a un petit moment ce que je trouve
moins intéressant c'est qu'en fait ça
vient changer c'est un peu différents il
y a une évolution alors vous savez de
façon sur les design après l'oeil
s'habitue au départ on montre des choses
et souvent ah ces arbit ça me plaît pas
trop comme dans l'automobile vous voyez
on avait des bagnoles et si vous
regardez les nouveaux modèles c'est
bizarre ouais j'aime bien j'aime pas et
puis quand vous regardez l'ancien modèle
votre œil c'est habitué à autre chose et
vous trouvez ça vieux en fait c'est ça
qui donne le vieillissement là on est
pas encore habitué mais je trouve ça
assez marrant et j'aime bien j'aime bien
le S22 ultra donc si c'est comme ça ça
me plaît pas mal je trouve que l'idée il
y a c'est cool on regarderait
effectivement ce format qui est un peu
différent voyez elle 23 et 23 plus un
peu plus grosse 23 ultra maximum ce qui
est intéressant c'est regarder c'est je
vous le dis une fois de plus au niveau
de la configuration photo on aurait bien
trois capteurs au niveau du S23 3
capteurs au niveau des 23 plus si on
dirait un peu plus haut niveau du ultra
alors on se dit grand-angle ultra
grand-angle téléobjectif de toute façon
on est sur les modèles les plus haut de
gamme on est sur la gamme photo donc ça
me paraît normal et là est-ce qu'on
aurait un petit capteur macro en plus
dédié c'est complètement possible bref
vous voyez donc ça on verra ça dans
quelques jours quand on aura tout qui
sera dévoilé autre image qui est montré
comme ça vous voyez au niveau de ses
smartphones donc on voit bien le format
alors il y a différentes couleurs du
noir on aurait dû blanc ça c'est
classique alors là si vous venez
regarder juste ici là regardez juste là
on voit bien qu'on a la petite partie
pour me déranger votre s-p qui serait
inclus directement à l'intérieur alors
on continue sur le côté donc là le petit
tiroir de carte SIM alors ça c'est
marrant sur les premières images qu'on
avait tout à l'heure de ce côté-là vous
voyez j'ai pas le tiroir de carte SIM
alors est-ce que ces images là c'est du
bullshit ou pas peut-être peut-être
peut-être en tout cas là on voit des
produits qui ont des petits ça ressemble
à des photos en fait ça ressemble pas
une création 3D du bordel parce que la
qualité de l'image elle est quand même
pas ouf donc bon je veux bien y croire
de l'autre côté je me trouve avec la
même chose et c'est ça qui est
intéressant regardez le bouton qui est
là volume et là le gros bouton là donc
moi je pense qu'en fait ce que va faire
ça me saoule a priori c'est ma petite
pensée à moi bouton de volume c'est
logique je pense que ça personne ici
bouton ON OFF avec capteur d'empreintes
digitale qui est suffisamment grand donc
ça c'est assez cool donc ça me paraît
pas mal sur la tranche why not et là je
veux bien croire un petit bouton de
Bixby Bixby peut-être que vous pourriez
la signer à notre assistant si vous
voulez pas Bixby si vous voulez Google
assistant pourquoi pas mais bon voilà
moi je pense plutôt à ça si on regarde
en dessous on a effectivement et bien de
la recharge en USB c'est ça me paraît
normal
le micro qui va être par là pour la
réduction de bruit fatalement pour
capter la ressembler sur le dessus
excusez-moi là le petit haut-parleur on
aura des haut-parleur stéréo avec un
autre parleur sur le dessus et
effectivement le rangement pour le SPN
et là on le voit hein c'est courbes qui
sont quand même vachement plus profilés
au niveau des 23 23 ultra alors que sur
le 23 plus vous voyez ça fait d'arrondi
et c'est il y a pas un côté carré mais
on n'est pas du tout dans le même courbe
alors là pour le coup ça changerait pas
par rapport à ce qu'on avait à la série
S22 mais bon why not c'est assez mignon
je vous montre quelques toutes petites
images S23 hein voyez comme ça aussi
avec une fois de plus ce grand capteur
sur le côté le petit bouton ici donc
c'est vraiment sensiblement la même
chose voilà pour les différentes photos
que j'ai publié là sur sur le web pour
vous montrer on retrouve bien
effectivement cette idée du tiroir de
carte SIM sur le côté donc ça c'est
vraiment une chose auquel je crois donc
voilà un petit peu alors après il y a
d'autres choses que je vais vous donner
quelques petites infos intéressantes
l'unepague c'est à dire le moment où
l'événement va être fait pour dévoiler
ses smartphones a priori ça serait le
premier février donc on regardera ça on
se parle ici d'une échéance à un mois ça
dépend à quel moment vous regardez cette
vidéo mais 1er février a priori c'est
smartphone serait dévoilé à noter que
effectivement ça c'est assez marrant il
y aurait une petite évolution au niveau
des batteries sur le S23 on aurait une
batterie de 3900 maheur versus 3700
avant donc on aurait 200 milliampères de
plus exactement la même chose sur le S23
ultra on passerait de 4005 à 4700
milliampères heure tandis que sur le 23
+ excusez-moi parce que sur le ultra au
restaurer sur une batterie de 5000
milliampères heure à noter que le S23
surchargerait en 25 watts maximum bien
évidemment le plus et le ultra en 45
watts voilà un peu pour les infos que
j'ai pu venir glaner ici alors après si
vous intéressez au coloris on l'a vu on
aurait du noir on aurait dû du blanc
minimum et puis les couleurs signatures
les couleurs que Samsung viendrait
travailler en termes de marketing alors
sur les 23 on aurait un petit light gold
donc on aurait un petit couleur or
légère clair je pense et un ping gold
donc une couleur un petit peu rose rose
or un petit mélange comme ça on se
retrouverait avec un S23 plus en couleur
rose et on aurait un ultra en verre donc
ça peut être assez cool assez aussi
d'ailleurs en parlant de ça j'ai des
petites photos là des petites images à
vous montrer de fuite d'image marketing
qui aurait fuité également donc on
retrouverait ce petit verre là vous
voyez au niveau du Galaxy S23 ultra on
retrouverait ce petit rose au niveau du
S23 et j'ai pas de 3 plus pardon et j'ai
pas de S23 là j'ai un autre ultra vous
voyez avec le vert donc le vert il est
assez sympa et une fois de plus est-ce
qu'on monte ici c'est ce que boss
Samsung est-ce que bosse toutes les
marques c'est la notion d'écosystème
c'est-à-dire que vous avez effectivement
un smartphone qui est le cœur de votre
écosystème numérique on retrouve en plus
des montres bien évidemment des galaxies
buds des écouteurs et ça c'est assez
marrant alors ce qui est assez marrant
c'est que sur ultravail nous montre deux
montres de montre avec des bracelets qui
sont assez différents est-ce qu'ils vont
venir annoncer des montres également
lors de l'empach c'est totalement
possible est-ce qu'il y aura deux
montres un peu différent comme ce qu'on
a vu chez Apple avec l'Apple Watch et
puis l'Apple watch ultra c'est
complètement possible également donc ça
c'est des choses qu'on suivra par contre
il y a aussi une rumeur qui vachement
intéressante qui dit qu'il pourrait
venir présenter leur nouveau PC les
Galaxy book au moment de Lomepal alors
la question c'est est-ce que c'est
Galaxy petit book on les aura en France
ou pas il y en a qui sont déjà arrivés
l'année dernière est-ce qu'ils vont
continuer à faire évoluer la gamme alors
il est évident qu'il y en a qui vont
sortir dans le monde entier ça ne s'est
pas arrêté dans le monde entier mais en
France il y a pas longtemps mon avis
plus donc ça se trouve et en fonction
des résultats des ventes qu'ils ont eu
en 2022 peut-être vont-ils développer la
gamme en 2023 en tout cas on regardera
ça ça s'intéressant voilà un peu pour ce
qu'on peut voir ici alors je voudrais
qu'on parle un peu du ultra
ultra c'est celui de gauche et le grand
plan ultra on a un peu une fiche
technique on commence à avoir un peu à
quoi il pourrait ressembler on aurait
exactement enfin quasiment le même
format que ce qu'on avait l'année
dernière les dimensions serait
sensiblement les mêmes il serait un peu
plus lourd 233 grammes versus 200 mg
autant dire ça change vraiment pas grand
chose ça même sauce la même recette on
aurait même taille d'écran 6,8 pouces
codage des plus 300088 par 1440 selon ça
serait la même chose alors la dernière
on avait une dalle dynamique à molette
2x et là nous annonce une dalle E6 Super
AMOLED ltpo 3.0 donc avoir effectivement
si ils vont ils restent une amie qui a
molette 2x s'ils font évoluer la techno
ou si on effectivement sur cette dalle
là à voir avoir également au niveau du
taux de rafraîchissement
la qualité derrière bien évidemment mais
quand on connaît le travail que fait
Samsung au niveau des capteurs le
travail qui font au niveau des optiques
ça pourrait être intéressant est-ce
qu'ils iraient booster monter jusqu'à un
capteur de 200 mégapixels tout en
sachant que ça c'est chouette le
stundragon 8 gène 2 qui va être dans ses
smartphones peut accepter un capteur qui
va maximum jusqu'à 200 mégapixels donc
est-ce que Samsung irait vous en mettre
un ici ou non est-ce qu'il y aurait un
intérêt oui non allez savoir en tout cas
on en parle peut-être minimum 108
maximum peut-être de 100 autre truc qui
est assez marrant intéressant si au
niveau des caméras de selfie on voit que
sur le S22 ultra l'année dernière en
2022 on avait un capteur de 40
mégapixels là cette année on pourrait
redescendre en nombre de mégapixels
aller sur un 12 mais avoir un autofocus
dual pixel l'autofocus on pourrait
l'avoir sur les trois smartphones donc
le truc est assez marrant donc ça
pourrait également venir améliorer tout
ce qui va être à fait en photo au niveau
des selfies à voir tout ça c'est marrant
bon on verra ça bien évidemment autre
info à venir avons donné au niveau du
ultra alors bien évidemment il y aura
une amélioration au niveau de la photo
déjà parce qu'on va voir une meilleure
capacité de calcul avec le stade dragon
8 gène 2 versus les xénon en France et
versus le centre dragon 8 gène 1 qu'on
avait aux États-Unis au Canada au-delà
de ça que ce nouveau processeur et sont
venus améliorer tout le rendu de l'image
au niveau de la gaspi je passe un petit
peu le truc un peu technique on irait
plus loin on aurait a priori de
meilleures photos si vous vous souvenez
je vous avais fait une vidéo l'année
dernière pour vous le dire au niveau du
S22 ultra le gros point fort de Samsung
c'était de montrer la photo et la vidéo
de nuit vous l'avez montré ça marchait
bien c'était cool là on dirait un peu
plus loin mais c'est pas là où il y
aurait la grosse révolution pour avoir
une grosse révolution il faudrait
attendre 2024 et le S 24 ultra chez
c'est loin faut regarder un petit peu
loin mais a priori on aura encore un
meilleur capteur ça me paraît logique
son meilleur capteur meilleur processeur
reviendrait aligner les planètes mais en
plus de ça on aura un nouveau mécanisme
au niveau du téléobjectif avec un zoom
optique qui passerait de x 4 x 9 à avoir
une fois de plus je prends des pincettes
mais c'est ce qui semble se profiler et
c'est ce que j'ai vu arriver donc la
grosse révolution n'arriverait pas en
2023 au niveau de la photo chez Samsung
ça serait une belle évolution par
rapport effectivement à 2022 mais grosse
révolution grosse révolution de légumes
une fois de plus pour être en 2024 autre
info qui est intéressante du côté de la
vidéo on aurait un petit upgrade là où
avec les S2 pourrait bien filmé au
maximum en 8k à 24 images par seconde là
en première filmée jusqu'en 30 images
par seconde donc on rajoutera un côté un
peu plus smooth un côté un peu plus
fluide léger très honnêtement on va se
mettre 6 images de plus par seconde mais
bon c'est déjà ça capacité de calcul
s'améliorant nouveau processeur ça
permettrait d'aller un poil plus loin on
annonce également une luminosité qui
serait améliorée alors il y a des infos
un peu contradictoires je vois
effectivement d'un côté 1750 000 ok bon
ça me semble c'est ce qu'on avait déjà
l'année dernière là on annonce 2200 Nice
maximum en termes de pic de luminosité
ça voudrait dire dédale qui serait très
lumineuse à voir ça m'aurait pas trop
taper au niveau de la batterie et si ça
réduirait pas drastiquement l'autonomie
ça je sais pas on verra bien évidemment
et puis il y a une autre fonctionnalité
qui pourrait arriver ça c'est du soft
c'est intéressant mais il faut
effectivement qu'il y ait aussi une
partie qui soit incorporée au niveau
matériel c'est la fonction satellite
d'urgence qu'on retrouve au niveau des
iPhone cette année ça pourrait arriver
également au niveau de ces galaxies S23
j'y croisé ça me paraît normal que quand
cette techno arrive chez un constructeur
on la retrouve chez d'autres
constructeurs dans le très haut de gamme
et chez Samsung ça me paraîtrait pas
déconnant donc vous voyez voilà un peu
la fiche technique le portrait-robot de
ces Samsung Galaxy S23 s23-23 plus S23
ultra pour 2023 bien évidemment je
trouve ça assez intéressant et enfin si
on veut faire une analyse de ce qu'on
voit ici c'est une
belle qu'on avait l'année dernière mais
il y a pas de trucs de fou il y a pas de
très gros changement avoir maintenant
comment est-ce que Samsung va venir
intégrer ça comment est-ce qu'ils vont
venir faire travailler le matériel et le
logiciel pourraient bien évidemment
garder guillemets ici bon voilà moi je
trouve ça assez cool ça serait des très
jolis smartphone mais je vous dis une
fois de plus il y a pas d'effet Wahoo tu
dis waouh ils ont mis une fonctionnalité
qui dingue alors on verra si
effectivement ils sont présentés le
premier février et on verra
effectivement comment va venir
travailler Samsung d'un point de vue
marketing ils vont travailler fatalement
à l'écosystème ils vont fatalement venir
dissocier un peu les produits S23 23
plus S23 ultra avec des messages
marketing qui seront un peu différents
d'un côté l'autre maintenant est-ce
qu'il y a des fonctionnalités un peu
cachées qu'on a pas vu qu'on ne sait pas
et comment est-ce qu'ils vont venir
intégrer tout ça et une fois de plus et
là où la surprise peut être belle c'est
que je vous le redis je voulais dire en
début de vidéo et je vous le dis
maintenant une fois de plus le stade
dragon 8 Jane II est un processeur qui
est tourné vers l'intelligence
artificielle comment est-ce que Samsung
est venu travailler avec Welcome quelle
nouvelle fonctionnalité à base d'IgA ils
sont venus ils viendrait en tout cas
intégrer dans ses smartphones et c'est à
mon avis là où va résider tout l'intérêt
des Samsung Galaxy S23 bien évidemment
ça on en reparlera bientôt donc pensez à
venir vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà
fait puis surtout cliquez sur la petite
cloche là comme ça vous serez notifié
dès qu'une prochaine vidéo arrivera et
notamment celle où je vous parlerai des
galaxies S23 je vous embrasse prenez
soin de vous et à très bientôt et
surtout si vous avez des idées vous sur
ce qui pourra arriver sur ces
smartphones vous voulez marquer en bas
dans les commentaires des bisous à
bientôt Ciao
[Musique]